welcome back Kevin
James our next guest not only played a
talented singer and songwriter on the
hit show Nashville he has one in real
life as well his debut solo album is
called love ain't pretty it's available
now wherever you get your music so check
it out everybody say hello to Friend of
the show Charles
[Music]
[Applause]
eston
all right so they gave him me extra cuz
we love Charles actually yeah I didn't
know this about you but you start and I
feel like I've known you for a bit but
like you started on Broadway I I started
on Broadway I didn't finish it I know
but I didn't know that well yeah I mean
I love that you New York suits you
really well I can tell that K it comes
right through the screen and um it
suited me for a quick minute I was in
Los Angeles and auditioned for the show
called Smokey Joe's Cafe it was a review
of the songs of Liber and sters so great
I pered that pop Choir in high school
you did well years before that I
auditioned for the Broadway show and I
just had a really great audition for
years before that I would get a vocal
audition for a Broadway show and they go
all right they want to see a call back
and I go uh For What and they say oh
they it's a dance audition I go well I
don't dance so I probably shouldn't go
do that yeah just show up and lie and
say you can no that's what they said
they just want to see if you can move
and apparently I can't move but anyway
this one audition I just was free and
loose I did a couple Elvis songs hound
dog Libra and stroler wrote hound dog
and Jail House Rock yeah and so I think
I Bamboozled them and then I went here
on Broadway and we were rehearsing in
the studios downtown and I looked around
and I was surrounded by people that were
just legit Broadway Talent my leading
lady was dele Lively and she was
unbelievable such a great dancer singer
and then I think it was about 3 weeks in
the director finally showed up to see
where we were and I could you see on his
face him watching me you know that thing
you have a impostor syndrome and you're
like I don't belong here and everybody's
going to figure that out I that all day
well they figured it out he looked at me
and he said in front of everybody he
stopped the whole thing goes let me ask
you a question do you dance and I said
well Jerry that falls under things you
should have asked at the
audition and uh and I said I'm doing my
best I will get it by Showtime I promise
you that uh about a week later he gave
me a very nice phone call and he said we
really appreciate your hard work but
we're going to have to so they recast
the role and uh what the first thing I
found out was that I had a contract so I
got paid for a year for not being in
that show that's like the one time
you're thankful for contract it was
unbelievable I'm at 6 months in I go to
my mailbox I'm like honey I got to I got
a bump at 6 months so and another thing
I found out is if I had done that show I
would not have been available to get on
Whose Line Is It Anyway which changed my
life being on that show for a number of
years and then a final couple two things
um years later six or eight years later
we're walking some fair in in LA and we
see Del
Lively and her husband who was the guy
they replaced me with oh all these
things had to happen they had three kids
they had one in her arm one in the
stroller one walking and they were
amazing and we talked and we leaving I
go I think it's very important that you
guys understand and know and remember
that you have all this piss you have
this paradise because Charles eston
can't
dance you're
welcome um so this is your first solo
album so are you excited about that or
nervous about that I'm really excited
you know by the time it's out you got
you just want to get it out I put out a
ton of singles over the years when you
know when I went to Nashville it really
opened music all the way open again like
it used it was a door that I sort of
stepped away from it was what I did
first in college I was in a band and all
those things but I end up doing the
acting that Drew me away I would
improvise songs on who line or things
like that but so from then I started
putting out a bunch of singles I think
I've always held the album as something
special because I grew up with albums
that actual stories they meant something
like when when you'd listen on the radio
and you'd hear a song and you
immediately knew the song that followed
it on the album you could hear it coming
or you knew the r and and so you know
albums like Born to Run where it was
like a mov to me and here comes meeting
across the river and jungle land and all
these things so I sort of held the album
in such high regard that I wanted to
take some time I wanted to figure out
who I am as an artist you knew that
instantly I'm so you just your voice you
know what I didn't you didn't no cuz you
know why I love everything I love every
kind of music so that's the hard thing
about me so you could sing like the
other great singers and you had to
slowly not sing well I just mean like
finding your own sound like when someone
says what is your sound I'm like I don't
know like I don't you know I guess pop
that's crazy to me because I would I
would think you would it seems to me you
know but I'm the same way like I've sung
like so many other people I started off
playing Buddy Holly in the West End and
on Whose Line that you'd be singing a
song like Sting or Bono or Neil Young or
whatever so by the time I got to
Nashville I was trying to figure out who
I am what I wanted to say I think that's
always evolving as well yeah because
it's your who you're inspired by as well
yeah do do you remember like your first
like I don't know your your first
concert you ever went to your first time
you were inspired by an actor that made
you want to act like yeah I mean I
watched you know stand specials Robert
Klein was a comedian that you know and
when you start doing standup you kind of
start taking on their Cadence and stuff
like that until you kind of we're all
imitators exactly so that was yeah for
sure yeah um okay everybody Charles is
performing for us later to stick around
it's so good all the lines are good in
it it's like very well written um and up
next it's a story that's very personal
for Charles we're going to meet an
incredibly Brave kid who fought cancer
and won yes now she's helping other kids
do the day and we'll be right back years
ago Charles went through an ordal that
no parent wants to experience at 2 and a
half years old his daughter was
diagnosed with leukemia thankfully she
got through it and today she is cancer
free but Charles knows how difficult
that roller coaster is for any kid and
for their family that's why he wanted to
meet our next guest she too is a
Childhood cancer survivor she is also
the founder of a huge nonprofit that
helps kids and their families worldwide
cope as they battle can
at age 15 she is one of our youngest rad
humans
[Applause]
ever all right y'all from the comic
Childhood Cancer Foundation please
welcome
Elana Char hello oh my God so nice to
meet you nice to meet you too such a big
oh that's so sweet thank you so much
she's a fan of Jesse on the Disney
Channel I played the dad on Jesse God
that's amazing I forget that part I
forget that I know it was such a long
time ago yeah it was you were just a
little kid then right I know you're so
old and wise now so how old were you
when you were diagnosed yeah so I was
actually diagnosed right before my eth
birthday in 2016 um it was such a
stressful time um my mom was sort of the
first one who realized that something
was wrong with me because I was limping
um she brought me to the hospital
immediately she rushed me to get help
obviously I didn't want to go because
hospitals are scary for kids my age um
but when I got the diagnosis everything
sort of changed after that um I had to
live in the hospital for one and a half
years I had nine cycles of chemo 15
surgeries it was the most significant
time of my life I can't even express how
much it affected me but um luckily I'm
six years cancer free right
now
I can't it's hard on you and it's hard
on your family I imagine your family
like what y'all went through and your
daughter was diagnosed like that
absolutely you you were in and out right
of hospitals well um when I hear her
tell the story it's our daughter was two
and a half when Addie was diagnosed and
she had about two years of chemotherapy
herself there she is we and so but I've
always thought it was an incredible
blessing that she was so young that she
didn't really understand any of it so it
was like a new day and she didn't know
she was going to be losing her hair she
didn't know that she had a spinal tap
the next day and that was a real
blessing when I see kids who are a
little bit older that Anana was old
enough to understand so much of what was
going on so it always um blows my mind
but I always find again and again when I
meet uh these kids that have been
through this that they you can already
tell she's different she has this
strength she has this Charisma this
power intelligence so um I'm not
surprised at all yeah explain the
foundation to everybody yeah so I'd like
to think that I turned my pain into an
opportunity I started it in 2020 with
the support of my family I couldn't have
done it without them um I wanted to help
the kids in the hospital who I had
connected with during my treatment it
started with that with only $900 in my
my piggy bank um but then it sort that's
a pretty good piggy
bank I don't know if my piggy bank ever
made that I bought too much music like
yeah I know after that it grew into a
$1.5 million charity um yeah we help
kids find financially emotionally um we
have gift bags that we deliver to the
hospital that we put items in based off
of what I went through we have socks um
squishies handmade cards um brochures if
they want to register for help um we pay
for medical bills um we've helped over
30,000 families worldwide we've
delivered 3,500 goodie bags we've had um
2,500 um celebrations and visits with
kids in the hospital I'd like to think
that all we do is for the kids um
especially knowing how far I've grown
since I beat cancer yeah beat it I love
saying it like that yeah yeah so you you
I don't know you you got your message
out in a very creative way I feel like
you were singing the National Anthem
right how how did that idea come about
yeah so I have been connected with music
long before I was diagnosed I've been
taking singing classes since I was six
years old um yeah I sang to other kids
in the hospital um I sang in talent
shows i' like to think it you know Su
them it helped them as well as it helped
me um so after I started my Foundation I
you know got opportunities like the Mets
game which was very exciting that was a
vital moment in sharing my experience
sharing my message um the cause um and
since then I've been using my voice to
help kids in the hospital um yeah yeah
well I know know that Charles you want
to say something to Elana right well
absolutely first of all um I think
sometimes you meet people and you go
this is somebody where cancer messed
with the wrong person yeah because
you're coming back and fighting it on
behalf of so many others um because of
our daughter Addie my wife Patty and I
started uh years ago a thing called team
Addie and we raised money for the
Leukemia and Lymphoma Society with Team
Addie and my question to you is have you
been to Nashville before have you been
to Music City I have not well I was
wondering if we could fly you to Music
City and you could be a part of our next
benefit concert would you do
that would you do that
okay pleas says oh sweetheart thank you
we appreciate that we thank you so much
you're going to love it if you like
music and I think people always think
when Nashville they just think country
music which it is obviously very much a
core part of that that City but
everybody's there like rock and roll
people singers songwriters blues singers
like it doesn't pop singers I live there
for like 12 years like every it's just a
place you can go if you love music and
it's therapeutic there's so many shows
to see so many places and people to meet
to network with it's a really cool
you're going to you're going to love it
I'm so excited yeah thank you Charles
thank you
[Music]
guys
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home